[Music]
all right mary so what's up how can i
help please no no no talking about
animals let's move on okay
um we're talking about people now so
good um a couple of weeks ago um my 15
year old daughter
just seemed like i was the only one
still awake everybody was asleep and she
came in the kitchen and
started crying and was you know just
saying that she was overwhelmed with
school
and all her sports and everything and
you know just not kind of
uncharacteristic of her to to be like
that but she does have sports every day
and school's a heavy load now that
they're all back in person and
we kind of talked a little bit about
that and got through that
i just said hey is there anything else
that's going on with you and
she goes yeah there's some things i need
to talk to you about and i was like well
let's go sit down on the couch hey hello
you you knew it was coming didn't you
i think i did yeah you do did you super
i know it's coming and i wasn't even
there
okay so hold on just for every parent of
a young kid you're about to get the
reverse talk which is all it's a worse
nightmare than the original talk and oh
yeah is your heart racing
like put everybody in your head in your
body when this was going on um
i think i expected this conversation at
some point but not this near this thing
and how old again is that i am kind of
like freaking out a little bit but i was
like okay we're gonna we're gonna we're
we were standing in the kitchen so i'm
like we're gonna go sit down
everybody else is asleep we can have a
good time right now
and
completely dark in the house
in the gym with a 15 year old daughter
15
15. okay
okay
and
um
just to prep everybody for what's about
to come is that
she's been dating this boy who we really
love
um
for
probably about nine months
and
she
proceeded to tell me that they have had
sexual intercourse and i
um i i was i maybe wasn't expecting that
part maybe i was expecting just
hey we've done some things and i'm so
glad that she feels open enough to even
talk to me about it right yeah okay hey
before we go further i just want to
pause there um that tells me that you've
got a great relationship with your
daughter so high five to you that's
that's a big deal um one of the
i think we can all
it's a mirage it's a it's a it's a myth
it's a fantasy to think that our kids
are going to get through
any
middle school high school college
without challenges
and the greatest gift you can give your
kid is the gift of trust that when they
find themselves over their head or
underwater they'll reach out to you so
good for you that's awesome that's years
and years of you being a trustworthy
person that she came to you so that's
great
well and i yeah like i said i just feel
so fortunate that that is the case
because
you know i mean i don't think i would
have ever had the guts to talk to my mom
about that
when i was her age
i've got two kids and me and my mom
still don't talk about that so yeah i'm
i mean well no i mean well that's kind
of a generational thing yeah actually we
do talk about it way too much in my
family but um anyway okay so you're in
the i'm trying to set the stage of
what's what almost a lifetime movie so
it goes from
reaching out in the kitchen to an in the
dark conversation and
walk me through what she's telling you
here
so she tells me that and she said i
you know
i feel like she goes you know
i think we need to talk about birth
control and i said well yeah that does
come along with sexual intercourse and i
said but
let's kind of backtrack a little bit
because
a i want to make sure that you
feel safe with this person and then i
also want to make sure that you're not
being pressured into doing something
that you're not ready for
and she was like no i don't feel
pressured at all and then that really
just kind of sends off alarm bells
because i'm like
i kind of wanted her to feel pressured
right
[Music]
and
she
it's not that she seemed fine with it
i think more than anything because she
said to me later she goes i'm just
worried you're going to think less of me
what was your response to that
i said
honey i would never
think less of you i said
i think more of you because you've come
to me to talk about it yeah
that's uh and
and really we
we just kind of talked through
and and i've had this talk with her
before just because even before the
boyfriend
my parents never had open conversations
with me about sex and so i was like i'm
going to be different with my kids
and i said to her you know
when she started high school is that you
know
you may become interested in boys and
they're definitely interested in girls
and
we kind of talked about all the things
that can happen and i don't want you to
ever feel pressured
and
also talked about what a big deal
sex is
emotionally and
how it really takes some maturity and
she
you know asked me a lot of questions
about
when was the first time i did were you
honest
i was totally honest with her awesome
but i was i just graduated from high
school and yeah i was probably still
pretty immature
at the time
but
so i i guess that's why i never dreamed
i'd be having
the conversation with her this early
yeah
[Music]
so how can i help you
so
moving forward i mean you know
the main thing that i made clear to her
is that
i and i didn't say this directly to her
but what i was thinking in my head is
that you just said that here's what you
just said
i made this super clear to her i didn't
really say it but you know what i mean
this is my head
i know how that sounds but
in my head i'm thinking to myself you
know
uh
you can always i just said sure a
situation
if you ever feel like this isn't working
or
that you
don't want to be doing this anymore
you don't have to do that you know you
can step back and and if this boy isn't
into that then he can hit the road
and she was she was like mom i know that
and she goes and i just want you to know
that my boyfriend has
been so respectful of me and
and
has never pressured me
and you know
of course they think they're in love
with each other as we all do with our
first
sure boyfriend or girlfriend
um
and i'm just so worried about her heart
being broken even more i just know for
me
um once you put sex into the equation it
changes everything
so mary um
i know you know this
but your 15 year old's a child
yes
and i mean she doesn't even have a
freaking license to drive a car and
that's what's gonna go as a society
we've all put our heads together and
said you know what 15 year olds are too
young to even drive
yeah 15 year olds are too young to buy
cigarettes they're too young to buy beer
they're tuned to buy
um
guns like we've put these restrictions
on
children
because
they make decisions based on connection
they make decisions on what feels good
right now they make decisions
that aren't thought out or wise
and that's why they desperately need
parents
and
this puts you in an incredibly awkward
position because the whole thing is
predicated on trust
right
right and we often back trust up to you
promise you won't tell and you promise
that
you
it's two of two things one you promise
you won't tell and
you promise you'll stand by with
whatever it is i'm doing and anything
beyond that is perceived as a violation
of trust and what i would say to you as
a parent and any parent dealing with
this
is
to
go one step beneath
this conversation
and look at your child reaching out
saying will you please help me will you
please protect me from myself
and that is a level of trust that is not
going to be
um
is not going to be at the forefront of a
15 year old brain which is why she's got
a mom
and
um
it's gonna feel it's gonna feel yucky in
the moment but
the thing she desperately needs is her
mom to step up and be mom
not best friend not older sister not
right we'll make good choices 15 year
olds can't make good choices because
they're 15.
you know what i mean
i i completely agree with you
so
i just need your advice on the best way
to direct that aside from forbidding
them to see each other you know right as
you said i let him maintain that level
of trust with her
and the reality is is that
both of them are going to be driving in
a few months
and if they continue to date
then
you know i
so i'm going to tell you something crazy
all right okay and this fits in i've had
this conversation with
atheists secular
um
researchers i've had this with
super jesus freak counselors and pastors
and everyone in between
15 year olds to younger sex 16 17 years
too young to be having sex
yeah they can create a human
they can um
they can it
i'm not going to go through the risks we
all know that stuff we're all grown up
the risks are immeasurable and we don't
let them take this type of risk with
anything else
and so what trust is going to look like
now what parenting is going to look like
now
is going to feel like a violation to a
15 year old
and it's going to be something that
comes along down the road
when your kid circles back and says
i'm so thankful that fill in the blank
that you cared enough about me
and it will be hard and it will be tears
and it will be use promised and i can't
believe you i hate you it'll be all that
stuff and there's seasons when that's
what parents have to take
yeah
but i have not met
the mental health professional
secular faith-based atheist
lunatic and we all know lunatic mental
health practitioners i haven't met the
one that's like yeah 15 year olds that's
great that's cool just make good choices
i haven't met them
because they're children
they can't make those kind of choices
and so
if my 16 year old kids are in that same
boat they're not driving
i'm taking them places
the same way as if i knew they were
sneaking alcohol or they were doing
drugs or they were
filling the blanket any other risky
behavior that a 15 year old or 16 year
old seven-year-old doesn't have the
brain capacity to to deal with
and you and i both know what adult sex
how that much that complicates stuff
it's complicated in marriage
much less
you know what i mean trying to figure
out what your body's doing yeah
and so all that to say is there is
you've heard me say before you know not
by your hand but in your lap your baby
girl so gracefully came and dropped us
in your lap
and i want you to hear it both as an
honoring of the parenting up until now
and a deep cry for help
okay
and it's gonna be so hard so hard
there's not an easy way out i'd
recommend calling his parents he's too
young to be having sex he's 15.
yeah
and bringing everybody in on it and your
daughter will go bananas
you know what i mean have you talked to
him about it yeah
i have not
and
um
but i do know the parents were getting
to know them better um
you're about to get to know them real
real well yeah yeah
and here's the thing you don't hate your
kids 15 year old sex is awesome 15 year
olds they're being 15. you know what i
mean
so they're not bad or broken they're 15.
and then suddenly they found themselves
over their heads
yeah and that's why they need us to step
in
no and i do think i mean it's
if i if i bring his parents in i mean
it's really going to only help
strengthen that they they're a great
family
strong ties with their kids
from what i know of them they're great
parents
um
and just good people yeah and so uh you
know i
i know it's not like if i go to them
and to their son to talk about it
that they're not going to you know brush
me off and say you know
pound sand
and here's the thing even if they did
even if you knew that was coming who
cares
you can only control you right so if
they're gonna tell you that you're an
idiot i can't believe you're calling us
they're just kids let them have fun
that's your decision and then it's your
daughter to protect
it's awesome that they're gonna they
they might potentially partner with you
on this
um the the big thing here is to make
sure your kids don't feel dirty or gross
or that they're somehow evil you know
what i mean and they may internalize
that and feel that great and here's the
other thing
if they want to have sex they'll figure
out a place to do it that's true right
they can get pretty creative
your job isn't to
i don't know
you don't create a police state at the
same time i'm going to do what i can in
my power to make sure my kids are safe
yeah
i'm going to make sure they're safe and
15 year olds having sex are not safe
for a hundred different reasons
yeah and so
does this surprise you that i'm saying
this or did you know this was coming and
you didn't you wanted me to say
something i mean really if you're you're
just the reinforcing voice that i needed
to hear
and i think part of the issue is that
um
things are really crazy in the state
that i live in as you may be aware
for example
if i take my daughter to the
pediatrician
i can only come into the room with her
permission that's right
at 13.
is when that starts yeah um
and so i mean you know she could have
just gone to our pediatrician and never
told me anything
um
and so you know i
i i think about that and i
just
hearing what you said re i mean it
reinforces what our family's values are
not only that
but also
where i need to take it from here and
you know i mean yeah i want to be
supportive of her and know
that
she knows that we love her no matter
what
but at the same time that our job as
parents is to keep her safe yeah that's
that's a line that i use in my house
since my kids were born in anticipation
of this very conversation someday
um and multiple other ones but my jobs
keep you safe do the best i can and i
can't keep you safe for forever two
things that i hear a lot from parents in
this situation one like you mentioned
um i was sexually active as a teenager
too
and either a it was awesome it was fine
nothing happened or b
i was pressured to do stuff i wasn't
comfortable with and i don't want to
talk to my kids about that
and so
either way your shame your
bad experience or
your guilt that you kind of it was kind
of awesome and
here we are in a dif it's a different
planet with cell phones and
everyone's got cameras the whole thing
is at another level
same as like i've heard back smoking
weed in the 70s was one thing smoking
weeds now with his high power it's just
different things are different
and understanding that we're on a
different planet
and i tell you what if i'd had a cell
phone with a camera
as a 15 year old i would be forever
unemployable forever you know what i
mean i would it would be a whole
different
yeah i can't even wrap my head around
that
um that's number one number two
you're right
you live in a state where
middle schoolers can go in
and leave their parents out of medical
decisions
that doesn't mean you stop parenting or
throw your hands up
and you do keep that relationship and if
your daughter wants to
move off the grid in that kind of in
that way
and your state supports that there's all
kinds of other conversations you all
need to have about where you live and
what your values are
most of the time
most of the time
kids default to that connected
relationship
and
they do not they will kick and scream
against accountability but deep down
they go
oh thank god i'm safe
i'm still wired in here
and that's why it's so important to
shame your kid for wanting to
be physically active with somebody and
they're kid of course they do it's
awesome
and that's why they need parents that
are going to love them walk alongside
them and say i'm putting up boundaries
because you're 15.
um
and yeah if your daughter goes and gets
birth control from a doctor and sneaks
it behind your back and you never find
out about it
there's not a whole lot you can do about
that until you until you do find out
about it
and again i'm not suggesting a police
state i am suggesting a heightened level
of awareness and a heightened level of
parental involvement
and making sure every parent's on the
same page and i'm not going to leave my
kid alone in my house i'm not going to
go out of town and let them stay at the
place
i'm going to be more present a lot more
present
all under the guise of i'm gonna keep my
kids safe i'm gonna keep my kids safe
i love you too much to
let you get over your head and or
underwater or the same thing right
um it's a tough road to hoe you got for
you but you have built up so many years
of relational connection there
and um
the play is now five years 10 years 15
years down the road that you loved your
daughter enough to step in and say hey
hey it's my job to help you stay safe
and it's gonna be uncomfortable for
everybody but i love you too much too
just say all right make good choices
she's lucky to have you she's lucky to
have you mary